Public key encryption or PKI uses a pair of public and private keys,
X.509 certificates to secure data.
In simple terms, a certificate authority issues
the keys and binds them to the identity of an entity.
Before that, a registration authority,
which could also be the certificate authority,
verifies that the entities who they claim to be.
The keys are large numbers with a mathematical relationship that is prohibitively time
consuming and expensive to discover using currently available computing technologies.
As a result, data encrypted using either key can only be unencrypted using the other one.
Importantly, the public key is freely shareable but the private key must remain secret.
However, as we will now see there are use cases for using either key to
encrypt something and the opposite key to decrypt it.
In the most common use case shown along the top,
the sender encrypts a document they wish to
share using the intended recipients public key.
Since only that recipient has the matching private key,
only they can decrypt and read the document.
As shown along the bottom,
PKI also involves a digital signature.
Its purpose is to prevent tampering and impersonation in digital communications.
Creating it involves hashing which is the transformation of a string of characters
into a usually shorter fixed length value or a key that represents the original string.
A hash is then encrypted using the sender's private key.
The encrypted hash along with
other information such as the hashing algorithm is the digital signature.
The reason for encrypting the hash instead of the entire message or document is that
a hash function can convert
an arbitrary input into a fixed length value which is usually much shorter.
This saves time since hashing is much faster than signing.
Any recipient can confirm the source of the document by
decrypting the digital signature using the sender's public key.
Please note that this in no way compromises the sender's private key.
It just confirms that the digital signature was encrypted using it.
Also since the document was in hash,
this does not compromise confidential patient information.